c'est vrai que tu disais le colis est là
qu vide c'est vrai qu'on en fait trop
justement il ya ludovic toro qui étaient
avec nous un médecin qui voudraient
s'entretenir avec ça avec toi sur ça en
fait en tronc en fait-on trop avec le co
ville ludovic tu peux rentrer des
rivières toujours là toujours arrivées
de sébastien au tamis de bach mais tout
va bien
laurent c'est vrai que ce que tu disais
tout à l'heure toi pour ton on en fait
trop oui on en fait trop pas face sur le
fait qu'il faille évidemment protéger
les plus âgés et les gens qui sont
atteintes de comorbidité qui
effectivement sont les premières
personnes ciblées mais on a fait on a
fait trop peur et on continue à vouloir
faire trop peur aux gens moi c'est ça
qui me fait qui m'embête c'est pas c'est
pas les conditions sanitaires
évidemment qu'il faut faire les gestes
barrière ceci cela très bien bon ça
quand même on en fait beaucoup là dessus
et je trouve que surtout on aurait mieux
fait depuis des années de mettre de
l'argent dans les hôpitaux dr fait mais
on continue à nous dire mais pour il
faut pas parce qu'il faut former des
gens il faut ce qu'il faut cela d'enfin
si dans trois ans il ya encore il ya
encore des variantes sais quoi d'autre
on continue on va nous dire ça et ça
fait et ça fera trois yachts est
d'accord récurrents je suis entièrement
d'accord récurrent je trouve que le le
constat il est terrible en fait ça fait
un an qu'on est censé combattre
l'épidémie à coups de confinement de
vaccination de geste barrières on n'a
jamais eu aussi peu de liberté que
maintenant on fait des attestations pour
tout et n'importe quoi on les met ce
pardon a fait ce qu il ya eu un tableau
on est même le pays tous pays confondus
cas était le plus strictes en termes non
seulement de confinement mais de
restriction unsa a été le pays le temps
n'a pas les meilleurs résultats pour
autant voilà et comme l'a dit laurent
c'est normal map sur une attestation
pour sortir son chien enfin moi je
trouve pas ça normal et on s'installe
vers une société où on va trouver ça
normal de se faire qu'on finira confiné
des confiné de faire contrôler par la
police tout le temps je trouve ça et
eric et de support se dessine moi je
suis partagé parce que il n'ya pas que
les morts dus qu'au guide
il ya des gens qui gardent des séquelles
hadji des séquelles extrêmement grave du
duc au vide et quand on a fait un tour
dans un hôpital et qu'on voit comment ça
se passe je sais ça here in aménas s'est
préparée je dis que je vais partager je
viens à la deuxième s'est en revanche il
ya un côté obsessionnel dans le cockpit
c'est à dire ici des émissions sur le co
vite qu'ils ne nous apprennent rien
chaque matin j'ouvre la radio et je me
dis mais qu'est ce qu'ils vont trouver
pour nous parler du copine il trouve à
chaque fois un angle et on n'apprend
rien donc il ya un côté obsessionnel et
anxiogène
moi je prends pas des chiffres on nous
fait peur avec des chiffres mais moi je
pensais que j'allais j'ai actualisé
ça sera une terrible par exemple à ces
dernières semaines et l inde brésil la
stella un mélange plein de cette
catastrophe nations dont les chaînes
catastrophe en nombre de morts bien sûr
mais voulait frapper aux portes et
d'allemand ça ça je peux vous dire
actuellement
vous avez fait le calcul mais je les
aide à aller chiffre d'affairé vous à
100 millions le ratio est beaucoup plus
faible pour l'instant en had que chez
nous en france alors à l'ajustement